now India's Supreme Court has given the
government four weeks to respond to more
than a hundred legal challenges to its
new citizenship law the citizenship
Amendment Act sparked weeks of protests
across the country
it gives persecuted minorities from
three neighboring countries the right to
apply for citizenship but excludes
Muslims
critics say the legislation is
discriminatory and petitions were filed
challenging its constitutional validity
well our correspondent Elizabeth puranam
joins us now live from New Delhi let's
talk us through what's been happening in
the courtroom today
Nastasia after six weeks of protests
since the citizenship Amendment Act was
passed the Supreme Court finally began
to hear the petitions against the law
there were more than a hundred and forty
petitions filed by all sorts of groups
civil society human rights organizations
political parties including the main
opposition Congress and the Indian Union
Muslim League and we are joined now by
the president of the Indian Union Muslim
League mr. K M cada Maha veer and mr.
Mohideen thank you for talking taking
time to talk to us on al Jazeera so
firstly why did your group file a
petition against the law at the Supreme
Court the citizenship Amendment Act
passed by the Parliament of India in
goes against the very spirit and letter
of the Indian Constitution Indian
Constitution upholds the secular
principles of our country but the Act
passed by the Parliament goes against a
very secular principle once our
president of India Radha Krishnan
cerebelli Radha Krishnan said in secular
India they can't be any discriminatory
legislation but it is a discriminatory
legislation and the only three countries
Muslim countries are named and Muslims
are excluded six other communities are
included this kind of discriminatory
legislation cannot be passed in the
parliament
therefore the very act power bill passed
by the Parliament which and now has
become an act is quite contradictory to
the very principle of the Constitution
it goes against the very spirit and
letter of the Constitution it should be
nullified as unconstitutional that's why
we indeed musubi has filed a case
against thee when I acted in the Supreme
Court and how hurtful I you that the
petition will get a fair hearing at the
Supreme Court again given that it was
passed by both houses of parliament by a
government that has such a strong
mandate a majority in this country right
now
the Parliament bill was passed not with
the thumping majority but there were
secured only 37 percent of the people's
verdict vote sixty-three percent of the
peoples of India had water against the
government therefore we can't say it is
the will of the majority people of India
then the bill passed in the parliament
with their brutal majority they say but
there's a bill has become now we were
arguing before the Honorable Supreme
Court we were observing the way in which
the Supreme Court has reacted it is
quite sympathetic the Supreme Court's
reaction was quite sympathetic we feel
and believe also that it may go to be
opacity also they have openly said
within four weeks time the government of
India should give all the answers to the
petitions and within the four weeks time
the Supreme Court will give some sort of
verdict either constituting a new
constitution bench to hear the bill do
you hear the case on a day-to-day basis
something like that or some other relief
also they may produce after four weeks
time that is our belief thank you very
much for your time so there is the
president of the Indian Union Muslim
League one of the parties that have
filed a petition and the government now
has four weeks and would that time given
to the government the protests that
we've seen around the country are set to
continue against the citizenship law and
that's a situation we'll continue
watching very closely Elizabeth puranam
there for us in New Delhi Thank You Liz